señoras
y señores congresistas
queridas
hermanas y hermanos
de nuestra querida patria
tengo el alto honor de estar en este
pleno extraordinario
para saludar en primer orden a todas y
todos los peruanos que no sin legítima
razón
vienen observando esta difícil coyuntura
que nos pone a prueba a todos los
ciudadanos
antes que política
soy una ciudadana y madre peruana que
tiene pleno conocimiento de la alta
responsabilidad que la historia pone en
mis hombros y atendiendo a esa alta
responsabilidad
va mi respeto por los millones de madres
peruanas que día a día procuran el
sustento para sus familias y son la base
del coraje y la peruanidad
como todos conocemos
Se ha producido un intento de golpe de
estado
una impronta promovida por el señor
Pedro Castillo que no he encontrado eco
en las instituciones de la democracia y
en la calle este congreso de la
República
atendiendo al mandato constitucional ha
tomado una decisión y es mi deber actuar
en consecuencia
asumo el cargo de presidenta
constitucional de la República siendo
consciente de la enorme responsabilidad
que me toca y mi primera invocación como
no podía ser de otra manera es convocar
a la más amplia unidad de todas y todos
los peruanos
nos corresponde
[Aplausos]
señoras y señores
conversar dialogar ponernos de acuerdo
algo tan sencillo como tan impracticable
en los últimos meses
convoco por ello a un amplio proceso de
diálogo entre todas las fuerzas
políticas representadas o no en el
congreso es imprescindible retomar la
agenda del crecimiento económico con
inclusión social del empleo digno de la
atención de emergencia para los sectores
vulnerables de pleno respeto de los
derechos fundamentales de los ciudadanos
y ciudadanas y también de manera
impostergable de la Reforma política que
nuestro país requiere urgentemente en
esta ocasión
hago un pedido también y muy concreto a
la representación nacional
Solicito una tregua política para
instalar un gobierno de unidad nacional
esta alta responsabilidad debe ser
asumida de consumo por todas y por todos
no voy a pedir ni podría hacerlo que no
que no fiscalicen a mi gobierno ni que
no se escruten las decisiones que se
tendrán que tomar lo que Solicito es un
plazo un tiempo valioso para rescatar a
nuestro país de la corrupción y el
desgobierno y por ello mi primera medida
será enfrentar a la corrupción en todas
las escabrosas dimensiones he visto con
repulsión como la frente y los
organismos jurisdiccionales han dado
cuenta de vergonzosos actos
de latrocinio en contra del dinero de
todos los peruanos
este cáncer se debe extirpar de raíz
por ello mi primera medida será
solicitar el apoyo de la Fiscalía de la
nación
de la procuraduría Pública para ingresar
sin medias tintas a las estructuras
corrompidas por las mafias al interior
del estado y se impulsen investigaciones
y sanciones rápidas
señoras y señores
necesitamos a los mejores peruanos
gobernar El Perú no será tarea fácil
Tendremos que constituir un gabinete de
toda la sangre donde estén representadas
todas las fuerzas democráticas para que
juntos podamos sacar a nuestra patria
adelante a nuestras fuerzas armadas y
Policía Nacional
instituciones fundamentales de la
democracia como lo hemos podido
verificar el día de hoy les digo
[Aplausos]
les digo
confíen en que el gobierno que se inicia
respetará su misión constitucional que
guarda relación con la seguridad de
todos los peruanos el militar y el
policía son en realidad como lo
mencionan nuestras constituciones
fundacionales los ciudadanos con el
uniforme de la patria
yo soy del país profundo
nací crecí un pueblito del Perú soy la
última hija de una numerosa familia
una familia que vivió en la precariedad
y creció en el afecto de mis padres
aprendí el trabajo
y la lealtad
ofrezco por eso hoy ante este Magno
poder del Estado
ardo trabajo para hacer un país viable y
reafirmo mi lealtad a la Constitución y
a las leyes de la república Y al pueblo
peruano al final de esta tarde no puedo
dejar de recordar a José María arguedas
al taitarguedas como le llamamos los
apurimeños quien quien enseñó que la
lucha es un bien el más grande el bien
que le ha sido
otorgado al hombre y en virtud a esa
enseñanza me comprometo ante el país a
luchar porque los nadies los excluidos
los ajenos tengan la oportunidad y el
acceso que históricamente se les ha
negado que vive el Perú Muchas gracias